heather how are we doing um so my
husband's
father is fixing to run out of money
next month
um we believe he is
mentally ill just undiagnosed okay and
we're just trying to figure out what to
do because he's
planning to be homeless
why
we're we're all unsure like
he called my husband father's day
weekend
and said hey i only have six months of
money
you and your brother come get what you
want from the house the rest is going to
the curb
and basically that's it like he's only
giving them
his junk with strings like they're not
allowed to give away
the junk he's giving them like it's
literally stuff that doesn't work and
everything has a price tag
but he's giving his house back to the
bank which doesn't make sense
i mean is he is he
man that that that sets off a lot of
alarms for me
that you're dealing with somebody that's
about to take their own life
and that's what everyone's asked and i'm
like i don't
see him doing that yeah but most
i don't say most folks often don't see
it coming because they think
that guy or would never do that or that
that that came out of nowhere
and then when they look back one of the
cornerstone moments is
calling people and saying come take what
you want and they start giving their
stuff away
i've never in fact i've never heard of a
planned homelessness
i've heard of people who sell all their
things to take an rv out to the woods
and they're going to live that way but
they've got a plan and adventure they
start selling everything so they can
have cash
i even read a book about a guy who just
chose to live cashless
and he volunteered and ate off the land
et cetera
but outside of some some significant
mental illness
um this sounds like somebody who's
on a dangerous trajectory there it needs
a a pretty immediate intervention
what does intervention look like has
your husband gone to visit with him and
speak with him in person
has his your brother's you know your
brother-in-law have they gone
really direct with him no
so it's a very complicated situation
with them
my husband is the main one that's close
to my father-in-law like my
father-in-law
never even actually told his other son
what was going on
my husband told his brother um
his dad actually told his brother that
he's like oh i'm just getting i'm just
cleaning out the house
and so he is not close with them
and then my father-in-law told my
husband that
when i can't afford gas in my car i'll
just come and park it in front of your
house
and then i i've been staying out of it
my my father-in-law
doesn't necessarily respect either of
his son's spouses or his sons
for the matter and
so i asked my husband i said so what is
he going to put on a backpack and walk
away
like what are his plans but i feel like
every time my husband or even my
brother-in-law get around him
it's like they become this little boy
yeah
so here's what has to happen is
your husband has to go to wherever he is
and even if he's in california or in
oregon
oh he's a mile down the road okay even
better
um i would put this at a code red
intervention level you're watching
somebody
cognitively dis like um disintegrate
in front of you and either they have a
really well thought out plan
to take their own life a really well
thought out plan
to just stop with the pain
that is life and they're going to do it
by just walking down the street
at which you're going to get a call from
the authorities four days later
or eight days later um
to come get him right and he will have
not eaten and not slept and if
god knows whatever traumas he's
accumulated in those few days
um but your husband's got to step up
and he's got to take his brothers with
him and you're going to have to
directly sit in the home of your
father-in-law
not you them and they're going to have
to have the conversation of what is the
plan you cannot do what you're doing
and this is either a an
extraordinary cry for help that
your husband is just not responding to
this is probably um your dad
your father-in-law has history of
erratic behavior and this just feels
like erratic
plus one and so unless i'm so glad
you're calling because unless
you're you know ten thousand feet away
from it it doesn't look as nutty it just
looks like
nutty plus one right just a little bit
more than dad's normal
chaos and there's some real red flags
here
so he he's been known up and down his
his mom had um i think my mother-in-law
said
she like my father-in-law's mom
was schizophrenic and um
bipolar and when she would get off her
meds she would try to commit suicide
and so we've all we're all like okay we
see this
in him but i feel like my husband has
given up on him
like i feel and he just he's like i
don't know what else to do
he's a grown man he he is and you know
what he's sometimes
he's sitting your husband's right your
husband's right
your his dad is a grown man at the end
of the day
if he wants to do something drastic he
can
and that's the heartbreaking thing about
loving people your husband probably has
a lifetime of exhaustion of dealing with
this too
and i get that as well um
there is a in a safety situation so your
husband does not have a lifetime of
abuse your husband doesn't have a
lifetime
of um having to
ward off his old man from from
trauma um from painful things
then there's there comes a moment when
you got to step in and save your dad
from himself
or and or um
he's got to have a safety plan at his
home too which means he needs to
look his father in the eye and say if
you park your car at my house i will
have it towed
you will not be welcome in my home
and i would tell you and i don't want to
talk bad about your husband
but if he's through with his dad
he has a moral and ethical obligation to
tell his dad
i'm through with you because it's not
fair to your
to a old guy to a to his dad who is
slowly losing it
not doing well on a significant
cognitive decline
to have a plan that is not going to be
is not going to be lived out in reality
and his own son won't be honest with him
and so for your husband's sake for and
here's the deal
it is for your husband's sake if your if
your father-in-law hauls off and does
take his own life
that will weigh on your husband's heart
for the rest of his life
if yeah he shows up at the front door
and it turns into a whole
melee in a situation and then after a
mess and then you and him have to fight
and
y'all got kids and and and anne and then
that car gets towed
eventually anyway you're gonna have
created a whole bunch of unnecessary
chaos because you didn't plan ahead
and so if i'm if i'm you the
conversation to be had
is number one you and your husband have
to sit down and co-create a plan for the
moment
his father pulls up in front of your
house and says i'm moving in the
backyard
are you gonna call the police are you
gonna call social services
um i know there are several um elder
mental health associations there in
houston
are you going to call one of them to
come get him
because it's not a character issue if if
he has schizophrenia it is not a
moral issue he's sick he's he's hurting
right um
and you need to sit down with your
husband and tell him you talk to deloney
on the radio he can call me tomorrow
but he has a moral and ethical
obligation as far as i'm concerned he
must go sit down with his father and say
what you're doing isn't um isn't a good
idea
you don't appear to be well you can't
just give your house back to the bank
you cannot just give all your stuff away
and wander off into the night we're
worried about you and we love you and we
care about you
let's get you the help you need and then
he's right he's got to be vulnerable
and then his dad's going to be able to
do whatever his dad wants to do
but your son and his brothers need to go
sit down and have that conversation
and here's the deal heather that sucks i
hate that for you i hate that for him
i hate that for everybody in that family
dealing with
advanced mental illness and a parent
is devastating so hard
but that's what we got to do so call me
back after those conversations i'd love
to hear how it plays out i want to hear
how
your husband i have confidence in him
he's going to step up and do the right
thing
and go sit down and have some hard hard
conversations i know that little boy
pops out every time dad shows up and
that little boy's got to be let go your
husband's got to step up and do the
right thing
and his brothers need to step up there
and be there with him too